some code collects dust and static state
while other code is in active use today
a software developer named jacob
thornton made a similar observation
about open source a few years ago
jacob is one of the creators of the
popular design framework bootstrap whose
contribution graph i showed you at the
beginning of this talk and before i
share this comment a lot of bit of
context which is that richard stallman
a long time programmer who started the
free software movement
which was open source's predecessor
famously said that free software is free
as in speech
but not free as in beer stallman was
trying to make the distinction between
the idea of
being free as in liberated versus free
as in zero cost
sometimes expressed with the spanish
words libre versus gratis
a distinction that's meant to highlight
how free software is an ideology
rather than about getting software for
free so
jacob riffed on this concept and he
tried to explain the problem of open
source requiring ongoing maintenance
jacob said that open source is free not
as in beer or speech
but free as in puppy i think this
metaphor is really good because it
forces us to think of software not as a
static object like beer but instead
consider the cost associated with its
being a living organism like a puppy
you don't just buy a puppy and put it in
your house and be done with it like you
could with a beer in the fridge
you have to feed it and take care of it
and make sure it's happy
getting a puppy much like writing
software signifies the beginning
not the end of a new chapter and with it
comes all these hidden costs associated
with its upkeep
you